[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm trying to create
it so it feels like it's
of an ancient tradition,
that it does come from people
figuring things out.
And some of their technology
is really representative
of their culture.
Use of jade, use of piercings,
use of body modifications.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It was an interesting
design challenge
because we were delving
into characters that needed
rebreathers when they
were above water,
and trying to create
that look for a series
of warriors that needed to
look fierce and amazing.
Being a warrior in that culture
is sort of an extreme thing,
and the idea of changing your
appearance in a way that would
actually allow for you to
breathe outside the water
becomes an important part
of who you are as a person,
and it almost marks you
for life in some ways.
We were looking at animals that
would surround them as things
that they could possibly
implement as looks
for themselves as warriors.
So for example, with
Attuma, the fact
that he's got a hammerhead
shark skull that he wears
as a sort of helmet or headdress
becomes something that's
meant to be intimidating.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The same sort of
thing with Namora,
where we're taking sort
of oversized lionfish fins
and having them become an
amazing headdress for her.
It became one of
the cooler visuals,
I think, that our team put out
there is these orcas with 15,
20, 30 different
Talokanil attached,
using the undersea animals
as essentially vehicles.
The idea of being underwater,
of exploring an entire culture
that would have developed
and grown and created
itself into something that
was a world power I think
is so much fun.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[CHANTING]